بالتالي اا استمرار هذه الاجراءات المسار
الجديد غير الواضح المليء بالاقالات
والتقلبات انتخابات شهدت مشاركه ضعيفه ما
الذي يؤثر في سلوك الرئيس ان لم يكن كل
ذلك ذكر انه المشيشه نفسه الذي قاله وغيره
من الاقالات التي تشهد عليها الان هو من
عينه
[تصفيق]
الراي حسب وصفت قبل قليل يرفض الحوار معهم
يرفض الحوار مع كل هذه القطاعات من اعطى
الرئيس صلاحيه ان يكون ذلك
شكرا لكاء عديد الاسئله كنت سالتني لكن
هاحاول نجمع الاسئله هذه موجوده عليهم في
في بعض الوقت
شكرا
بالاتحاد العام التونسي بالتونسي بالشغل
في معك بعيد
منظمه وطنيه
همم تحسين الوضع عن الاقتصادي الوضع
المنظوريها من العمال ومن النقان
همم لا غبار عليه فمن حقي الاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل ان يفضي ويتحرك ويتحرك
احتجاجا او ما اراده وما ارتائه همم
حسين الوضع العام والاقتصاد البلاد لكن
خلينا نتحدث على ما قام به خيط تتعيط
عندما اعلن اقل رئيس حي الصعيد يوم
25 هل
وضع اثنين
من حبك كثير من الاخصر تحت كليمه الوضع
الاستثنائي وما يحدث الان هو وضعه
استثنائيه ونحن في حاله طوارئ
ادعونا نكمل هذه المرحله التي تنتهي بهذا
البرلمان الذي سيكون ان شاء الله ممكن يوم
8 يقوم همم يعني جلسه اداء اليمين وتعود
الدوله التونسيه الى دواليب
ديت واحنا يمر اذا الى ما تريدونه ده
والراجل ده رجل يكمول تلك المرحله
واتصادوا لذلك القرار الكل اجمع على لانه
يوم 25 جويريه حتى اليوم هناك من موجود
خارج في الشارع اليوم مثل عبير موسى وحيد
بصير الحره
احب العمال مثل الطيار ديمقراطي بالنسبه
الكعادي موجوده
وتلك اللحظه التاريخيه لاننا لم نعرف
نحتمل تلك العصريه السوداء
همم
الوضع الاستثنائي
ان نقودها
استثناءات مثل المراسيين مثل الاوامر
فلذلك نحن وضعيف فلنعود الى دوليب الدوله
العاديه